la forêt c'est un immense garde manger
qui comporte des cycles de
renouvellement bien précis ça peut
sembler anarchique
une année on dirait qu'il pleut des
cocottes c'est un buffet à volonté
tandis que l'année suivante c'est la
disette
et pourtant ces cycles ne relève pas du
hasard et les animaux ont appris à s'y
adapter
[Musique]
dans la forêt boréale en plein hiver le
chant des oiseaux créer une ambiance de
printemps nous sommes dans la forêt
montmorency au nord de québec et le
professeur ornithologues andré
desrochers s'intéresse un visiteur venu
en grand nombre à l'hiver 2020 le bec
croisille bifaces y est l'hiver 2019
2020 va passer
au livre guinness des records des
croisés
by facile à la forêt montmorency à du
coq parce qu'on en a dénombré en fait on
n'en a pas vu autant depuis au moins une
quinzaine d'années environ le viread
observations faites le bec croisille
beef acier est en pleine édification en
plein hiver actuellement en fait c'est
ça on est en pleine saison de
reproduction
c'était un morceau qui sait ce qui est
assez impressionnant parce qu'il peut
faire très froid on peut être à plein
mois de février peut envoyer et mal de
carl plumage rouge en parade nuptiale
ils vont faire des vols planés l'eau au
dessus des arbres qui vont chanter en
même temps et pis pas un comportement
qu'on s'attendrait de voir en plein
hiver parce que le studio sont encore en
amont sur ville
mais ces zozos l'énergie peuvent nicher
carrément au mois de janvier là
comme son nom l'indiqué le bec croisé by
fassiez à lebbeke croisés ce mec est
spécialement adapté pour ouvrir les
comptes d'épinettes les fameuses
cocottes avec son bec
il sépare les écailles pour y retirer
les graines sa nourriture préférée
cet oiseau de la famille des fragilités
et nomade donc difficile pour les
chercheurs de suivre sa trace on
aimerait bien voir une estimation de la
population des becs croiser ims
extrêmement du ciel va cesser d auto
jusqu'à demain que sont nomades alors
les oncologues de métier vont en baggy
par exemple des oiseaux puis de cette
manière là on peut avoir une estimation
plus précise des noms d'études mais site
d'alizay croisés le problème c'est que
des gros chance de ne plus jamais revoir
des oiseaux bagués parce qu'ils peuvent
aussi bien se retrouver à plusieurs
kilomètres de là les boeufs
cette année et se trouvait dans la
région de québec puis l'année prochaine
ils peuvent aussi bien se trouver au
manitoba en saskatchewan dont sont
capables de se déplacer sur des grandes
distances
mais c'est un ajout qui cycliques quand
même quelques années on n'a pas du tout
le même amant ou que dans le radar de
son idole décidément et arrivent de
nulle part puis s'installe ce qu'on vit
en ce moment
si le bec croisille by fassiez se
retrouvent ici en grand nombre c'est
qu'il suit l'offre de nourriture et à
l'hiver 2020 en forêt boréale
il y a eu une explosion de comptes dans
les conifères sont un peu peinturés dans
un coin d'une certaine manière parce
qu'ils sont excellents pour manger des
cônes du coût d'un très mauvais pour
manger autre chose donc sans vraiment
associer outre étroitement la production
en comble dans les forêts
mais cette production abondante de
compte ne sert pas seulement le bec
trois idées fassiez elle favorise aussi
l'écureuil roux ça fait des années qu'on
fait des relevés de mammifères et c'est
la forêt montmorency en faisant des
dénombrements des pistes dans la neige
évidemment ça nous donne pas un nombre
exact d'écureuils mais c'est clair que
plusieurs pistes peu plus ça nous
indique que les écureuils sont abondants
g cet hiver on voit les pistes des curés
partout à la forêt morose c'est un
animal qui mangent pas juste des cons
images des fruits puis aussi les gens
vont peut-être est étonné d'apprendre ça
mais c'est un animal qui va faire de la
prédation de nid d'oiseau vont manger
des yeux puis des oisillons alors
l'ornithologue à moi me fait un peu
redoutée ce qui s'en vient cet été parce
que là on a une grosse production
on a eu cet automne une grosse
production d'écureuil pendant une belle
survie d'écureuil cet hiver de sa
musique voir beaucoup de prédateurs
c'est l'été prochain mais qu'est ce qui
explique l'abondance de compte dont
profite en écureuil et oiseaux cela
résulte d'un cycle de reproduction des
forêts ce que l'on appelle les années
semencière où tous les arbres dans la
forêt sont en mode de reproduction
si tous les arbres produisent du pollen
produisent des fleurs produisent d'école
durant la même année toutes les
ressources sont dépensés durant ces
années là bas le succès de haut niveau
de la pollinisation que la fertilisation
des décomptes et meilleur hockey parce
que plus de pollen qui circulent çà fait
une meilleure année de production compte
[Musique]
mathieu bouchard analyse ce cycle
d'année semencière pour en déterminer la
fréquence et l'ampleur on regarde hui
pour y voir plus clair il doit d'abord
choisir un arbre vivant assez vieux on
cible ici un sapin baumier c'est parce
que des places pour la faire tomber
on en vérifie l'âge à l'aide d'une
carotte forêt dans le tronc
[Musique]
on occupe et l'air puisque ça nous
permet de voir c'est vraiment la
production de plomb qui est situé dans
la partie vraiment au-delà donc qu ici
on a la portion qui est maintenant de
19,5 m de haut puis on a la portion un
peut-être deux ou trois mètres le
supérieur où la production de kong était
vraiment concentré donc les cocottes des
apps sont situés à une simple analyse à
vue d'oeil des branches du conifère
permet de voir les années semencières on
voit très bien les pousses qui ont eu
lieu durant chaque année sociale a posté
eu lieu en 2009
en 2018 en 2017 dont on est capable
comme ça de reconstruire la croissance
de l'herbe si on est capable de voir
lorsque d'anciennes années de production
dont une analyse plus poussée en
laboratoire permettra de bien quantifier
ces années de reproduction mais déjà le
chercheur confirme l'importance de cette
dernière année financière
ce qu'on voit ce sont des restes des
comptes qui ont été produites durant
l'automne et l'hiver dernier les
écailles sont tombés donc ça laisse des
piques
puis il y en a énormément donc tout seul
à tous ces petits spectateurs convoi
s'était la production tombe de l'an
passé donc on voit que c'est une très
très grosse année après ça il faut
retourner peut-être jusqu'en 2006 le mi5
domicile sur une très grosse année 1995
donc c'est peut-être au disant d'euros
là où on a des années très très très
important la forêt vie donc des cycles
de renouvellement et de reproduction
naturelle
mais surtout elle vit sur des cycles
bien établis ou toute la forêt répond en
même temps ce qui explique ces cinq rené
ce plan à grande échelle c'est le fait
que les arbres répondent à des signaux
météorologiques et climatiques assez
précis donc lorsqu'un été relativement
chaud et sec
tous les arbres en même temps sont
capables de le percevoir puis au fil de
l'évolution naturelle c'est une façon
qu'ils ont trouvé les arts au fait de
l'évolution d'être capable de
synchroniser les années semencière en
utilisant les signaux climatique
on sait que ça arrive pas deux années de
suite parce que là lorsqu'une grosse
année comme sûr et puis ici réserve puis
l'année d'après il doit se reconstituer
même si la météo très favorable en
europe une très grosse année ça
mentionne en espaçant les grosses années
semencière ça fait qu'il ait pas de
population soit d'insectes granivores ou
de mammifères ou d'oiseaux granivores
qui peuvent se bâtir comment donner ces
populations ne devienne 13 tellement
importante qui est chaque année elle
mange tous les cons ok donc une façon
carbone a trouvé d'essayer de contourner
un petit peu ce problème yeux assez
d'espacé les années semencière début
juillet andré desrochers retourne à la
forêt montmorency pour faire cette fois
son dénombrement annuel des populations
d'oiseaux
[Musique]
grâce à des enregistrements de
différents cris et chants ils attirent
les oiseaux pour les compter parce qu'on
peut avoir un contact visuel avec les
oiseaux
ça nous permet de déterminer
et c'est des oiseaux qui sont en mode
orientale puis comment détermine sa main
s'ils transportent la nourriture dans
leur bec un peu comme les merles d'en
accrocher nou lé alors les oiseaux en
forêt vont nous indiquer qu'ils sont en
reproduction de cette manière
andré desrochers menottes ses
observations sur la reproduction aller
après année depuis 1995
cette année il observe que les becs 3
ebe phase i ont déjà quittés mais que
les écureuils roux sont encore bien
présents cette année il ya vraiment eu
une explosion de la population donc ça
ccc dans la lancée de ce qu'on a observé
ou dans la foulée de ce qu'on observait
l'hiver dernier où il y avait des traces
des curés partout dans la neige par
exemple lors des 1000 points et de
stations d'observation d'oiseaux
je note aussi tout vocalisation une
présence d'écureuils puis je te dirai
qui a environ 90% des endroits où enfin
nous relever d'oiseaux ou des notes la
présence et security et c'est vraiment
très élevés qui cherchait à l'aise de
dire qu'il doit y avoir trois ou quatre
fois plus des curieux que de qu'à
l'habitude de cette année après analyse
la saison de reproduction a été
lourdement touchée par la trop grande
présence d'écureuils
mais pour les chercheurs tout cela ne
relève pas du hasard mais bien du cycle
de vie dans la forêt c'était un
environnement où il ya la quantité de
ressources illimitées un donc beaucoup
de compétitions en toutes les espèces
les arts d 1 sec les animaux pour
arriver à compléter leur sébile capitale
dont qu'ils ont chacun de ces groupes
l'eau chacun de ces espèces l'eau à
développer des mécanismes équipe qui
sait juste pour s'ajuster les uns aux
autres pour être capable d'être toujours
de gagner cette espèce de compétition
l'eau ça sonne un peu comme un cliché de
dire que tout est interrelié ça fait
longtemps qu'on dise appui aérien plus
vexée en réalité et je dirais que j'irai
plus loin en disant que tout est relié
de manière non linéaire et complexe je
vois ce cyclope et je me dis ben la
nature en a probablement vu d'autres
[Musique]